good morning and good evening everyone
i just wanted to say how much i loved
this doc and i'm so looking forward to
people
being able to see it um so one of the
things in the doc
is you guys played this 21 night thing
in london where you performed all your
albums
and it was you know months of you guys
rehearsing and i'm just curious if you
still have ptsd
from trying to put this on absolutely to
the to the point where we'll
never do it again but i mean every every
time i look back on it
uh in the abstract uh it
it was an incredible thing to do and and
something i
doubt that any other ban will ever do
but
but kind of thinking of the details of
the in particular the preparation the
the performances were
were you know just really exciting but
the preparation for it was
uh you know uh uh quite a long tour in
afghanistan actually so
edgar i have to ask because you had
never made a dock before
was it tough to get financing was it you
know getting the money to make this
it was a snap
um he just we just we just said how much
do you want
and you know like i've known
of the band for like since i was like
five years old having seen them on
british tv
and that making like an impact on me and
then
this is in a pre-internet age where you
can only rely on what you
see and hear and maybe like can find in
the local library
i don't remember my small town having
music magazines particularly
i don't ever remember seeing even the
nme in my local news agent
so following sparks in that way was
quite kind of like a riddle in itself in
terms of
i saw them on tv in 1979 i had a couple
of
songs on vinyl on these chart
compilations and then it wasn't until i
was a teenager and i was getting into
some david bowie and roxy music and
t-rex
that like i'd hear these other spark
songs that were like clearly the same
band but it wasn't the same genre
and it came before the ones i knew
before so now i was properly confused
and then in the mid 90s ronald russell
had a hit in the uk with a song called
when do i get to sing my way
which had a great video that was
everywhere and they were on tv quite a
lot
and now i'm sort of truly baffled
because i was like these are the same
guys what's going on and like again
it took me quite a long time to figure
that out and i guess you know in more
recent years i say more recent years in
the last 20 years
with the internet and also with the kind
of i guess like a run of albums starting
with little beethoven
i was kind of more and more confounded
that a band that had been going for
decades was
producing new music that was you know
as good as anything that they'd done
which isn't usually the trajectory of
bands
things seem to kind of like tail off and
sometimes get embarrassing
um but that wasn't the case of sparks
and so they felt like a real anomaly
and that started to sort of my obsession
with them started to build up to the
thing where i wanted
an answer to this and and i felt like
they
i felt like they should be bigger than
they were but i felt the part of the
thing that was holding them back was
the sort of the context for some people
i i knew people i'd speak to
when i'd say like oh are you into sparks
they say oh yeah i want to get into
sparks where do i start they've got such
a daunting discography
so so then that turned into a couple of
things that happened i'll
just go through them really quickly
they're both quite funny one i was
writing baby driver
there was one afternoon where michael
bacall the screenwriter who just got
playing with me came into the office
and we were just chatting i was running
ideas past him
and we were talking about sparks and he
knew one spark song
which was all everything all i ever
think about is sex from 1983
and i said oh man you've got to hear
this album and this album and then as we
were working we were just playing like a
sparks marathon all day
and then at some point in the evening i
thought i wonder if sparks are on
twitter
so i looked at spark's twitter account
and it said sparks follows you
and i was like like because i
you know without really knowing ron and
russell just
from the their image you're kind of not
entirely sure that they live on planet
earth so to find that they
were they do and then either they on
twitter but i
direct messaged russell who replied
immediately
and i said oh is this really you guys or
is this a publicist running this account
i said oh no we really run it
and then i was even more like bemused to
find they obviously live in los angeles
and live only
20 minutes away from where i currently
was
so within like 24 hours i was having
breakfast with ronald russell
which after like you know years of
loving sparks was quite a kind of trip
for me
and then i went to see a couple of shows
and it was a show in 2017 um
at the el rey where i was with another
fellow sparks fan phil lord who you know
steve
and um we were in the balcony and
we were standing in between like steve
jones from the sex pistols
and tony basil of mickey fame and i was
looking at the crowd that were like
quite diverse in their age like between
like 16 and 60 and i thought that was
really interesting and i said phil i
said
i think the only thing that's stopping
sparks from being as big as they could
be is this
if there was a documentary about them
they're like the the best band who's
never had a documentary about them
and i think if there was some kind of
overview it would really kind of like
sort of let people who don't know who
sparks are
the whole story and phil just said you
should make that documentary and i was
like i will
and then i pitched it to ronald russell
that night and they they can tell you
what their response to that was but
in terms of raising the money i mean one
of the the good things about this is the
mrc who financed it had made baby driver
and they had just started a documentary
wing so i think they were quite
surprised themselves when i held my hand
up and said oh
i want to make a documentary so they
were like amazing kind of like sort of
um
supportive of the idea and have just
been with it from day one so
i wouldn't say it's been easy because
we've spent two and a half years making
this but they've been
like sort of on board with the idea
since the start of it and
you know and obviously i think as music
documentaries go there's elements of it
that are quite ambitious
so i think i kind of just went into it
as i would any other project
um i knew it was going to be a lot of
work so i wasn't surprised but it was
still like
felt like really going on a little
adventure so
that's a very long answer to a short
question ron and russell before you
answer because i do want you to answer
you have a history of uh movies and you
guys not working out
so when edgar you know comes to the
dressing room
whatever and says i want to do a
documentary
are you immediately like yeah sure this
is never going to happen
well we're we're kind of uh still so
naive i think in a good sense i think
that's what keeps
sparks fresh to a certain point is that
we're always
a gog at everything so when so when
edgar did
come backstage after the one show and
proposed this idea we just we said
you know we both said this is fantastic
uh
and we i think we just said this one's
going to be the one that's going to
break the mold
of our past uh dealings with movie
projects that hadn't come to fruition
so uh and you know we i think what was
more the case was we'd been
kind of hesitant in the past to even
want to do a documentary about the band
because we always feel that
what we're doing musically in the image
of the band and the
album artwork all that those sorts of
things speak louder
than what we can say about ourselves and
we were we were concerned that maybe
it would be a lesser impact to know more
about the ban
and so but but we when edgar proposed
this we
we're such fans of his work and we know
all of his films really well
and we thought that the sensibility of
what edgar
could potentially bring and hopefully
would bring
to the documentary would be really
complementary with what
sparks is and we just wanted it to be
something that was really um
you know on the same wavelength as
sparks that we knew from day one that
edgar had
that that that was the case with edgar
and we knew
that would be the the case because you
know um
just edgar's films are have
music plays a part in in in a lot of
them in a big way
and the sensibility that edgar has
in his films um we thought if
he could bring you know 10 of that into
this documentary we would be happy but
we were you know we were
it was a case of us hoping that we would
get a a
a big dose of edgar slapped on the
on the documentary and you know and so
we had no hesitation i mean it was the
opposite we were
we were thrilled and we just said yes
let's
do this and here we are uh two and a
half three years later
uh and it's it's actually been done i'm
curious if there was any sort of talk
about not not things being off limits
but maybe was there like any um
uh any debate over certain like scenes
being
certain things being included or was it
a very amicable
edit with you know everyone just
throwing flowers in the air saying it's
great
well i think the only thing that like
and this speaks to actually what becomes
some of my favorite moments in the
documentary
is the only thing that ronald russell
said to me was that they didn't want to
necessarily delve too much into their
personal lives in terms of
love lives and things and then what i do
what i do think is funny in the
documentary
is those little moments where you you
can't help but not talk about it and
even where it's sort of like you kind of
like have to
not like break character but like you
literally break down in a sentence like
i won't spoil it but one of my favorite
bits is where russell is trying to say
something in a diplomatic way
and ron's smirk gets wider and wider to
the point where they like break down
and i think those bits are like to me
i'm so glad that you guys let me leave
all of that in because that to me is
like the gold in a way and so
i think i mean i'll ask you this
question like
you had that one kind of thing that was
sort of off limits but then
there is stuff in the movie that's like
gets kind of personal but
i'm very happy that you were on board
with that staying in you know
no we i think we felt that that um
you know uh most documentaries you see
about bands there's always the angle of
that that's kind of obvious you know
like
like oh it's the they they were able to
uh resurrect themselves from the huge
drug
problems they had you know their
drinking problem you know and
after rehab they came back and and isn't
it a heartwarming story in that
that way or uh you know there's there's
usually a built-in
angle and so so we were concerned that
um you know we didn't have the the drug
problem we didn't have the the thing
that the other brother
brothers acts have of being kind of
contentious with each other so that
wasn't couldn't be the angle
either so so we're kind of thinking god
do we do sparks even have an
angle you know what what is our what is
our thing and so we're
happy that edgar you know chose to have
things where it showed not only the
complete career and every
period throughout the career every
single album throughout the career but
also
um treating them you know where there
were
really positive positive things
happening with us
and even the times when there weren't
you know great things happening for the
band maybe on a commercial
level that he also deals with those and
so um
you know those might have been things
like oh gee can you not
talk about those but i think that makes
the the documentary be richer
that that it that it isn't kind of this
just uh
love fest for the the entire career that
there's been no obstacles
everything's fine we don't take drugs
the brothers
don't hate each other so what can you
talk about but
but edgar you know managed to
to make this story be some like we think
it's a really
a good story you know whether it's
sparks or not sparks but just the idea
of like the
perseverance and through you know all
through all situations and obstacles
that sort of story we think it kind of
maybe will resonate to to an audience as
well
and to you know people wanting to become
get into being in the band or
whatever the situation is wanting to do
some creative endeavor that that's kind
of
the story that there is there's really
no
heroism in involved i mean there first
of all we don't really have a choice i
mean this is kind of
all that we can do and the other thing
is
we you know we've always felt that that
there's like a mission that we're on a
cause
and you know we just really want to
force that
cause you know in as as strong away as
we can
so you know those kind of moments where
where there is kind of
a downturn at least in some other
people's
eyes that that we just we just kind of
plow on and try to put blinders on at
those moments
it's not too late for you guys to delve
into heavy drug use i mean maybe
it's exactly the time to start if
if if my vaccine can't er appointment is
cancelled i might be starting at that
moment so
it's young kids about to go south real
fast
yeah yeah so you guys obviously
uh have gotten along your whole lives
have has the biggest fight
you've both had about like uh has it
been like where to go get lunch
or have you actually had contentious
arguments where you guys
like we're away from each other for a
week
i mean i was just going to say it you
know it's it's usually kind of matters
of
within within what we're doing working
wise very specific things like
like you know whether a song is worth
uh becoming a part of of an album or not
and you know there there have been you
know in general i write
most of the material and there have been
some songs where russell felt that
that lyrically the the lyrics
we we always write the music first and
then the lyrics come afterwards and that
that he felt that maybe the lyrical
slant
wasn't at the level of of what it was
musically uh or didn't match the
the mood so we you know we get into
discussions
in that kind of way but you know it's
never
it's never at the point where uh we go
sulk uh on our own for a week or two
i could be wrong about this but i want
to say you've been on 14 labels
through your career and i am curious
which one was your favorite of the 14 uh
labels
well i have to give special credit you
know to to island
island records and and chris blackwell
in the
in the in the in the middle
70s i mean he he he's a very
enigmatic figure and uh
and you know he he has such a an amazi
he has
you know at that time you know that
label was so special because it was a
an incredible combination of people so
you know and and also was the a label
that
that took a chance on us brought us to
england we had no we had two albums out
previously in the states but we had
no material to demonstrate to them it
was only their
their faith in what they thought we
could
do if we assemble the british band
around us so
you know i i think you know chris
blackwell is a real
visionary and you know it is it is
harder to find
those kind of people nowadays
but uh i give you know special credit to
him
after people see this doc definitely
people are going to want to
uh experience your music in a way that
they have not before
you have a lot of albums out for each of
you
for someone who's just going to buy a
sparks album
what is the album you want them to start
on to get them
into sparks we can triangulate this i
think russell can go first
oh i'm first i'm first well i i
i guess um reverting back to ron's
comments about ireland
you know kimono my house maybe is a good
starting point
just because it sort of was the album
that
launched the band in a in a more visible
way and
it had a an impact on a lot of um
not not only the public especially in in
europe
but also on other bands that were kind
of
uh youngsters at that time and
that saw saw the ban on top of the pops
and uh kind of said i want to
do that sort of thing too uh when i grow
up
and uh so it was a it was pretty
influential album so maybe that one
would be my
choice well i i'm gonna pick because i i
know where ron's gonna veer so i'm gonna
pick
number one in heaven 1979 which is the
album that ronald russell did with
georgio moroda
which is also not only like a drastic
change of sound for sparks to sort of
change from a rock band into an
electronic band
but also kind of so ahead of the curve
in terms of it's the sound of
the 80s in 1979 and in fact the album
was actually recorded in 1978
and sort of languished without a label
to pick it up so it could have been
two years ahead of its time but it
really is an extraordinary album and
also just kind of like a lot of things
in sparks world just like a little bit
ahead of its time in a good way
i'm kind of an indecisive person so i'll
i'll choose one of our
compilation albums uh new music for
amnesiacs
which offers a pretty broad view of what
we've done
over time and would give somebody if
they have the
patience to to get through the whole
thing uh
a really good idea of what a sampler of
what we've done through the years
did you guys ever use the music that you
were going to do with tim burton with my
the psychic girl
in an album or is that music still
dormant somewhere
yeah it's still it's still yeah it still
exists
and uh who knows maybe one day uh
tim will uh reenter the fold but we you
know we
we i'll be brief because i know you we
don't have much time but
tim actually um resurfaced after the
original time that we had done that
saying i've been thinking about this
project for years uh
it was been in the back of my head you
still have the music
we went we met with jim again like those
probably
was it 20 years after yes probably 10
years ago
10 years ago that we met him again after
the initial period
in uh and then he's in the and he
listened to the music again
and he said yeah it's everything that i
thought it was and had hoped for
let's make this movie and that was ten
years ago so
in any case the music is still there the
project is still there
and you know it's it we like it it's
been in development since 1991
so uh edgar uh true or false
you made this doc so you could hear the
music that no one else has heard
uh because you wanted to hear the my the
psychic girl uh music
i mean uh no not necessarily actually i
haven't actually heard the whole thing
i mean you know it's also worth pointing
out as a little sort of
you know the the funny thing like you
said about kind of like some near misses
in film
that obviously this year there are
actually two sparks films because
there's my documentary and then
leos characters annette so actually like
another sparks musical has beaten
um my the psychic girl out of the traps
um
but no i've never actually heard the
whole thing and uh
and now i'm thinking that uh i should
[Laughter]
we'll hook you up thank you um i'm
basically out of time but edgar i have
to ask you an individual question
um obviously i'm so looking forward to
whatever you might be doing this year
what what are you working on this year
as your next
thing i literally just before christmas
finished um
the sparks brothers and last night in
sephora in the same week which has never
happened to me before i've never worked
on two films at the same time
and i've never had to literally sign off
on both of them on the same day which is
what i did on the 21st of december
it's a very like weird day to watch last
night in soho
at one facility like dolby and walk over
to technicolor and watch the sparks
brothers
so and now obviously we're doing the
press for this so i'm in this period of
just
developing all the things i currently am
working on and you know in terms of that
the world that we live in
i don't necessarily for sure know
exactly what's next
when they ask me about certain projects
i'm like well there's also
the practicalities of how to make it in
the current uh
sort of uh situation that we're in but
you know i there's lots of exciting
things that i'm sort of working on so
it will be one of those got it listen
and i mean this seriously congrats on
the film
i know everyone's gonna love it i really
had about 72 other questions
so when the movie is eventually going to
come out uh i hope we can talk again
where i can ask the other things like
animation
the editing there's so many things um
but
seriously congrats on the movie um i'm
so happy i got to talk to you guys
thank you thank you steve so much thanks
a lot have a great day and good luck
with your speed dating
nice to see you steve nice to see you
and seriously everyone be safe
thank you